welcome back coffee drinkers have
pumpkin spice and beer lovers have
Oktoberfest joining us today to tell us
more is Wendy Force the president of the
Nevada craft Brewers Association and
she's also the owner of craft house
welcome thank you thank you I didn't
wear my Lederhosen you were dressed in
the parts sorry it was at the cleaners
right it was yes it was going to clean
for next week so how many how many
Brewers are are part of the association
um approximately 42 Brewers throughout
the entire state of Nevada are members
of the Nevada craft Brewers Association
every time you come on the show you
bring so many delicious beers what beers
did you bring with us today what makes
them so special for October so all of
these beers are fall themed or
Oktoberfest themed so we do have two
seasonal Oktoberfest one from bad beat
and one from Tanaya Creek love lady put
a pumpkin in their stout okay uh craft
house has cuckoo that's a Munich Dinko
lager and this is your your craft house
is your spotty of downtown is still
Henderson as well correct okay what's
yours what do you have uh this is big
dogs Brewing that's their Vienna okay
lager what's yours what do you do for
yours cuckoo it's a Munich Dunkle lager
so Dunkle just means dark in German how
do you come up with these things well a
lot of it is traditional historic Styles
and then something fun like the gas
station pumpkin patch is a style that
Brewers like to be creative and make up
on their own so they put pumpkin in
there they put baking spices so
creativity is is the the feed for the
Brewer's mind when do you guys start
brewing the stuff when you start making
this how is this they take to make your
bats where do you guys start that so
lagers take a little bit longer so if
you're bringing a lager it can take
about four to five weeks to finish out
and also ales they are a little bit
shorter it takes about two weeks but
Brewers plan just like fashion designers
plan we plan ahead of time and we start
planning at least two seasons ahead of
time why is it fall I feel like fall is
the time to drink beer I mean you can
drink beer year round but something
about the fall weather why is fall so
special when it comes to beer uh well
you want to be out on the patio for sure
the temperatures have dropped and
there's also great food to pair with it
and then your palette starts warming up
so you want those spices and you want
things that have malt character to them
that are roasted or toasted are you how
often are you downtown at craft house a
couple times a week you're the expert so
I love coming down and talking about the
beers and what I'm drinking and that's
what you do there someone's watching
right now they want to get this beer how
do they get the beer that we see here so
go to uh envybeer.com and then there's a
link with all of our members across the
state and then you can browse their
websites and see what they're offering
for fall supporting local beer at the
fall October real fast what is this
thing called here uh that's a Stein
is this time and this is this is
authentic is it not yeah it feels
authentic it is
thank you thank you Wendy appreciate it
it's time to check in with Rocky and see
what she's up to